season five of Good Witch what can we
expect where do you guys go in season
five well grace is in her last year of
high school which is really exciting she
had a boyfriend last evening I already
tell you how great you look things are
perfect right here things might not be
going too great with that but it doesn't
mean that new love can't be in the air
there's a lot of growing and there's a
lot of love and I think that it's a it's
just a really honest season I'm excited
for the families to get to see it we saw
recently you went on this epic ski trip
with Selena Gomez and a bunch of guys as
friends how do you know Selena so that I
did with his really plays together but
our mutual friend Connor had kind of
thrown it together and she was like um I
needed a pick-me-up and it was a good
time to be surrounded by good people and
I needed Matt then more than ever and so
it was really lovely sweet why did you
need to pick me up everyone needs to
pick me up at some point but it was just
like a personal thing and my girls were
surrounding me and I was really grateful
for it what is it like having Selena as
a friend I feel like she's just the
sweetest human ever she's lovely I mean
I don't get to see her as often as I
would love but anytime that I do she's
always been nothing but gracious to me
and kind and it's nice to be kind of the
little one in the business growing up
and getting to have a lot of beautiful
big sisters to get to look up to say do
you look at her as almost like a mentor
in a kind of way yeah I think I think me
as long as like with other millions of
girls do and I'm just fortunate to have
gotten to have conversations with her
and she's beautiful inside and out and
it's nice to have someone like her in
our day and age to get to look up to
what are you doing for Valentine's Day I
don't know I just texted my girlfriends
I was like galantine say anyone and then
I put unless one of us gets a date and
then anyone can leave but no I think I
think it's time for the ladies to come
together this year so I'm excited for it
[Music]